[Music]
these eyes aren't real in fact their
contact lenses it takes a very precise
skilled type of artist to make them
today we're going to find out how
they're made by eye works for film and
they make contact lenses for James Bond
Star Wars and even Game of Thrones we're
gonna see how they're produced here and
even get fitted with some lenses of our
own heavy ones Beverly Hills optometrist
Ruben Greene's beam is credited with
first using lenses to augment a
character's appearance
Grinspoon was tasked with changing an
actor's eyes from natural Brown to blue
in 1939 miracles for sale
he created a blue ceramic material which
was glazed the lens was attached and run
through a kiln to fuse the glass and
ceramic together leaving a round
aperture of four millimeters since
hydrogel soft contact lenses went into
mass production in 1971 lenses with
simple color pigments have become pretty
accessible but designing and painting
bespoke lenses is still an art form
so irritate your eyes at first actors
wear contacts to change their color
pigment to look older create
imperfections or even transform into
another species
this is Sinead Sweeney one of the
directors of I works for film the
companies worked on some big Hollywood
movies the idea of the contact lens will
either come from the makeup designer or
the prosthetic department or
occasionally just from the director so
they will approach us maybe with the
character brief or just an idea in which
case we would research a lot about that
look and then develop some concept art
some designs
first Sinead has got to check that the
actors eyes are suitable for lenses she
does a prescription check she then
checks the inside of the retina with an
ophthalmoscope and takes a 3d scan so we
want to make sure that the lens sits
exactly over the cornea so that when
you're wearing the contact lens or when
our actors are wearing them that that
feels very very normal
further checks look at the curve of the
eye the diameter of the iris and the
front of the eye for dryness using a
yellow dye called fluorescent I thought
about new actors on set you're on set
for a really long time and how do you
stop your eyes from getting really dry
it was really we insert and remove the
lenses for them because their hands
might be covered in grease paint or
blood and so then we monitor them we put
drops in throughout the day and we only
limit the wearing time really we don't
allow them to wear them too long there's
a trick to putting large lenses in chin
up
then eyes down to the left feel like you
have an entire film over your eye now so
it's just it I can picture that what
really puts on into character quite
quickly the lenses take two to three
weeks to paint and manufacture but for
the purposes of filming here are some
that we made earlier we're going to
return in just a bit to see how these
ones turn out manufacturers like number
seven make the prescription lenses and
then a lens artists such as Kristina
Patterson from eye ink FX paints them by
hand using fda-approved paint the lenses
are then shipped and applied on set time
suddenly is key when it comes to the
makeup so even one brushstroke too far
can make a real difference it's really
really special and specific pigments
that we use obviously anything that
you're going to put on a lens that is
you know ultimately going to go into
someone's eye it really isn't just any
pigment there are a lot of safety
guidelines and also the lenses are
sterilized extremely fine brushes yeah
and you have to have a quite an amazing
artist in order to deliver certain
textures and looks the detail is
extremely fine a man who's very similar
actually in design to a lot of the Star
Trek lenses which repent these lenses
were painted by the same artist I've
really got that kind of bug-eyed fishy
look going on but though yeah there is
something videoing about it detail here
is incredible it's the most strange
feeling because they feel really jelly
light but they look so glazed like
ceramics the lens is flattened to your
eye so it's important to get rid of air
bubbles and keep putting in drops if
we're gonna sell this as an actual
creature the pupil would always be in
the same place so make sure that the
lens is stabilized I think one of the
biggest issues we have with that is
actually when someone is lying down
because the lenses are wasted so they
tend to want to fall with gravity to the
lowest point so if you can imagine
you've got your lenses sitting like a
cat's eye for example and then they lie
down everything kind of swings and
they're not the only lenses in the
building
Sinead keeps cases of celebrity eyes
from productions the company's worked on
serpent or make eye looks that we used
on David Tennant on Good Omens
so we've got our night king when you see
them in this show they have a post glow
which is added in CG and also we put
some pixelated points on there which
with the effects they could work with
that to pull the glow effect out they
weren't the original blue
I also got in here I love that you're
saying who else either all people the
company has made lenses for penny
dreadful and Specter these are the
mountains from Game of Thrones well that
was a fascinating process I can't
believe my eyes looked like that that
celebrity eye graveyard that we saw at
the end if my contact lenses can make it
into there I'll be very very happy it's
clear the industry has come a long way
so it's just being able to change eye
color in 1939 now thanks to this movie
magic actors can become all sorts of
creatures
[Music]
you